i'm a google developer expert in web
technologies more specifically my focus
is on angular and google maps these days
i started working with angularjs and
front-end development
a long time ago back in 2011. so what
is a progressive web app so when we
build a progressive web app what we're
doing
is that we are working
on a way to have one code base instead
of
three the idea is you build a web app
and that web app is going to be
your app that's going to work for the
web in a browser
and is also going to be what you use on
android and
on ios for mobile devices so the idea is
you write the code just
once and then all of your users no
matter
their platform are gonna be um
are gonna be using that same web app
so this is something that's uh that's
been kind of
a dream for for a long time to be able
to have one code base
and then just you that code on any
platform and not having to maintain
an android application an ios
application
and a web application so pw is help a
lot with that
one of the main things with pwas is to
make that
a possibility a reality
so we'll see how how it helps and and
what uh
what are the features that we have
available to help with that
um the main big thing about pw is
is to reduce friction and what i mean by
friction
is that when you go to a store you have
to
well first go to this app store then
look for an application
you'll be presented with tons of options
usually
so you have to pick which app you
actually want to install
and then you're gonna install it and if
you're
lucky meaning if you live in a place
where you have pretty good network
and lte is stable and all of that
then the download is gonna happen in a
few seconds
minutes usually seconds but if you're
not that fortunate
which in most of the world is is really
not the case
people are still using 3g in in a lot of
different countries
uh when you're asked to download 250
megabytes of
application code that is just friction
meaning people can't do that or it will
take forever and they just give up
so regular native apps have that issue
that they are huge
they are really huge and and and it can
be frustrating from time to time that
you know um a common example that
happens to me all the time
is i have my insurance company
and um instead of sending me the
documents my proof of insurance they say
hey use our app
so i'm like okay that's a good idea i
can use an app to do that
if i ever have to need that document i
could use the app
and just put it up and and i have the
document
well the thing is when you get to
download the app you realize it's at
least
50 100 megabytes of code just
to show a pdf to someone so that's
that's a little bit too much
so regular mobile apps are big usually
and and that's an issue that's that's a
thing that
can prevent you from having your
application
downloaded by users because they don't
have network they don't have the space
on their phone but that's also a thing
uh that that happens very frequently
in the us people like to get the latest
phones and they're fairly up to date
and and they have devices with tons of
space
but uh in developing countries that's
not the case they still have phones that
we would have here uh five six years ago
so there are
there are more space limited they have
all of these
restrictions that we don't have anymore
so as a result installing big apps is a
problem and
if we want to have an app that's really
easy to install for everyone
no matter where they are no matter what
their phone is
pwa is is a great option so the idea is
and it's it almost sounds too good to be
true uh when you use a progressive web
app
it's it's win-win all over the place in
the sense that
it's gonna be fast for the user it's
gonna be an easy experience
they don't have to go to an app store uh
and and and the download is gonna be
pretty much painless
because what you're giving the user is a
web app
so if they know about your web app it's
because
they are already displaying it in the
browser and if they're displaying it in
the browser they already have
the code downloaded which means they're
all set
um so pwa is really
using the web technologies and and and
building upon on top of that to make
things uh
even easier for us developers to to make
those apps accessible on all platforms
so this sounds absolutely absolutely
great i'm going to write my code
in html javascript css and
everyone is going to be able to use it
and i don't have to worry about the app
stores
so seems like something that everyone
would want right
and and people wonder well is it just a
marketing speech that you're doing here
does this actually exist pwas do exist
and one of the most
widely used um pwa
is this one so this is the progressive
web app from starbucks
and when you think about it a business
like
a coffee shop like starbucks they want
you to to be able to use the app to to
order
and to pay in just a few seconds so
for them it's really super important
that you don't have to download 200
megabytes of code
and wait before you can do your order it
has to be instant
so a pwa from their perspective
makes perfect sense and and and there's
a
lot
of use cases where you just want to you
know get this app to show up do
something and you're done
and you're not going to use it for a few
days uh after that
so so pwas are fast
and uh so this one the one from
starbucks
i'm actually going to show you a quick
demo
because by showing you a demo i'm going
to show you what
a progressive web app actually does
what it can do and what are the
different features behind
behind it
so demoing on a phone is is not easy at
a conference because a lot of things can
go wrong
so i recorded my screen and i'm playing
a video right now
so on my phone i'm going to google and
i'm going to look for starbucks so this
brings me to this app
the starbucks pwa is the one that's
going to show up right away
and you can see that at the bottom of my
screen
there is this this kind of
pop-up that that showed up that says add
starbucks to
home screen so this is the progressive
web app prompt that comes from that
website this is a website running in a
browser
but now it is prompting me hey do you
want to install do you want to add this
to your home screen
so i'm going to exit that i'm going to
say okay i i use starbucks pretty pretty
often so i'm going to tap
on that banner
and when i do so i'm gonna have
a confirmation that's gonna show up
there it
is do you really want to add starbucks
to your home screen
yes or no and if i do it
then the install is is happening in the
background
and that install is really just adding a
link
to my home screen so now i have the
starbucks logo in there
and that's my pwa installed so it just
happens in one or two seconds because
all of the code is already there and
when i tap on it
you can see that the starbucks app shows
up again
but the rendering is slightly different
than before
because if you look at the top of the
screen
there's no browser url anymore
it is now showing up full screen so i'm
not running this
in in chrome or in any browser anymore
this is the app taking its own entire
space just
like a regular native app would do
the banner at two home screen is gone as
well
and so i'm gonna
toggle between different apps so we can
see that
even more easily there you go so now
if i use the android application
switcher you can see at the very bottom
of my screen that there is a starbucks
app that is showing
up that's my pwa with the starbucks logo
and and the theme the green color and
all of that
and on top of that there's my google
chrome which which still has starbucks
open because i went there earlier
but the app is now different it's now
separated from from a browser and it's
live it has its own lifecycle really
it's as if we took
that browser tab and we turned it into
its own app that's that's really what it
is doing
um and of course just like any app you
can kill it from here so i could just
close it close everything uh switch
between those apps
and you can see that the behavior is
really just like
a native application
so now next thing i'm going to do is
just close all of my apps so i just
close the pwa
and i'm going to tap back on on
starbucks
and when i do so i'm gonna pause so i'm
gonna pause right now usually it's
pretty quick
but i want it to pause so you can see
that there is a splash screen
showing up with pwas so that's another
behavior
that a progressive web app brings to the
table you can add a splash screen with
your logo your text
your theme anything you want to
customize
that splash screen usually it goes away
pretty quick because again
all of the javascript html css was
already downloaded
so the app just shows up right away
and is ready to be used so from a user
perspective
it's great it's just super fast you
install in one second
you just load the application in one
second as well um and
and that's that's a great great thing
so these are the basic features that any
progressive web app would have um
so installability from from a browser so
this prompt that's going to say
hey do you want to um do you want to
install this pwa on
on your device then you have this
shortcut it's it's really a shortcut on
your home screen
to navigate back to that application and
uh and and and then you can have some
so we'll get into the more advanced
features um
very soon but these are the basic
characteristics using the splash screen
loading full screen showing up on the
home screen of your phone
once you have that you have a
progressive web app
and what's important to remember is that
all of this is just html javascript and
css there is no
native code here at this point
and i just use basic html javascript css
and sold it as starbucks for for their
own pwa
so there's more to progressive web apps
we saw that the basic behavior
but because the idea is to behave like
a truly native application progressive
web apps
can do notifications as well so
you can you know try to re-engage the
user by notifying
um uh adding that that notification is
going to look
and and feel like your native one it's
just gonna behave the same way
so for starbucks that could be saying
hey your order is ready you can pick it
up
pick it up right now or all that kind of
thing
another big feature is offline
capability
by caching data images and
extra javascript up front you can make
your pwa work offline
now of course not all apps are meant to
be working offline
because some of them do require a server
for for interactions with with the back
end but if you have
if your app has a few features that make
sense to make available offline
you can also do that and
finally you can uninstall so just like
we can install
you can uninstall the app which is
really just going to clear the cache
on on the device to remove everything
that got
installed earlier
so now that we saw what a progressive
web app looks like
i'm pretty sure that you want to know
how do i make one
what is what is required to to build a
pwa because this sounds great
so how do i get started
this is actually the best part of it
because building a pwa
is incredibly easy in the sense
that you can do it without even writing
any
code the bare minimum required for a
progressive web app
is two things the first one
a manifest file so a manifest.json
which is really going to be a config of
what the pwa should look like so it's
it's really giving a name
to your app giving an icon defining how
the splash scr
what the splash screen should look like
um what are what are the colors that
you're going to use
the theme um all of these different
things so you want your app to show at
full screen or just like a regular
browser application
all of these sort of information that's
what's going to go into manifest.json
if you have that manifest and you add it
to your web app
so in your index.html you will just have
a
reference to that manifest.json just
like you reference
external css or javascript you would
load the manifest json
and then the browser is going to
recognize that and as the browser sees
that manifest it's just going to enable
all of the all of the features that we
just saw so the
install prompt the splash screen
the icon everything just comes from that
manifest
there is another second there is a
second thing that is required so the
manifest
in itself is going to um
to enable these features if you
if your app is running on https and
that's the other very important thing
that is absolutely needed
if you want a pwa you need a certificate
on your backend you need ssl you need
https
if you just do regular http then the
browser is not gonna
pick up the manifest json and it's not
gonna enable that behavior
so that's the two things that you need
https
and manifest.json if you have these two
you have a progressive web app so this
can be done
in in five minutes really uh we will see
a few tools
that can actually help generate the
manifest json
um but that's that's all you need these
two things you have a pwa
that can get installed splashscreen all
of that
if you want to get into more advanced
features
then you are going to need a service
worker
a service worker is a script so this is
javascript code
that you can set up to do all of the
caching
so if you want to do offline with your
app
you would write a service worker that is
going to specify
um what you want to cache so this css
file this font
these images these data requests to the
backend all of that
i want it to be cached and only a
service worker can do that
same thing for notifications if you want
to to do the native
notification support it would have to
happen
through that service worker
because the nice thing with with service
worker
is that it is going to run in your
browser kind of like a background
process you can you can really
think of a service worker as a script
it's always there in the background and
uh and that can send requests to your
server
even when the user is not um
is not using your application so that
service worker could call
your server ask for some info and then
show a notification even if your app is
not actively
uh running in in the browser
so these are very very powerful things
and
if if you're not familiar with the idea
of the service worker
i'm pretty sure that you've seen that
you've
at least seen one in action recently
because
over the past couple of years it's
become very
popular for blogs or
news websites to just to just ask you
hey do you want to get notifications
from us
and if you say yes then the service
worker is going to get there
it's gonna be basically pull their back
end
uh in the background and send you a
notification hey we have this new post
that showed up hey we have this new
article ready for you
and all of those features rely on
service worker
so you can use service worker without a
pwa it doesn't have to be just for a
progressive web app
but usually progressive web apps are a
nice
addition service worker are nice
addition to a progressive web app
because of the offline capability and
the native notifications
so i mentioned um
i mentioned a manifesto json the file
that we need
to enable progressive web apps and
that's an example
that's what it looks like
um so again it's just a simple json
object that has keys and values
and these keys are um while the name of
your app
a shorter name starts url the kind of
display that you want
so here it is set to standalone which
means it's going to
show and behave like a standalone native
app
as a background color to use for
the splash screen and the header the
description of your app
and then a set of all of the icons that
you want to use
so all of you you can add as many
sizes and definitions as you want to
support
ultra high def screens or smaller phones
as well
and that's really the only part that
that's kind of native
having to provide all of these different
icons
you don't need to provide hundreds
hundreds of them by the way just one or
two can
can do uh it it really depends on how
good you want them to look like on any
sort of device
so this manifest json um is is a config
file
really keys and values and if you
want to create your own you can use
a generator so there's this one
which comes from google so
appmanifest.firebaseapp.com
if you go there you can just enter a
bunch of values
and then click a generate button and you
have your manifest.json
so that's um that's as easy as it gets
you fill out a form
click a button and you can download your
manifest
that you just then include to your index
html
and you're all good to go you have a
progressive web app
so on the side of service workers in
terms of
syntax it can be a little bit more
complex
because that's where you're going to
have all of the
logic that you want to implement if you
do pre-caching
or while caching alone or pre-caching
which means
fetching data and images up front
so that the app would keep working if
you go offline
so in that code example we see a first
block where we define
a bunch of urls that we want to
pre-cache so here's the index.html
all of the styles and a dmod.js
and then the service worker is has its
listener code
that is going to make sure that
everything gets installed
and once the app is ready add all of the
precache urls and
and and try to download them and cache
them
so writing a service worker can be
complex
there's a lot of things you can do with
service worker and in terms of syntax
it can get a little bit tricky
which is the reason why there are more
and more libraries
to help with this and one of the most
popular library used to date for for
this
is called workbox so warbucks is a
library that
has all of the um let's say shortcuts
to help you uh with the boilerplate that
would be needed to write a service
worker
so roblox knows about uh pre-caching
runtime caching all of the different
strategies that you want to use for
caching
such as do i try to get new data every
time i'm
online or do i just always use the cache
how often do i want to refresh that data
once a day
once a month never that's that's up to
you you can
define all of these strategies and
workbox
enables all of that in a in a pretty
straightforward way
routing background sync debugging and
uh yeah basically brings a ton of
features on top of service worker
to make it easy to to create your own
service worker
and and and build some features on top
of it
so if my example earlier was
using the starbucks application so if we
want to take a look
at how they've done it uh you can go to
that
website app.starbucks.com in in your
browser
so i'm using google chrome and in chrome
i opened
the dev tools and in the dev tools i
went to the application tab
and in that application tab you can see
that at the top so top left corner of
the dev tools
we have this section where we can click
on manifest
and that would show us the manifest.json
used by uh by starbucks in that case
i can even open this open this one in a
new tab
and that shows me exactly what their
manifest looks
like so they actually kept it pretty
nice
and easy it's fairly straightforward
only two different sort of icons
and they also added references
links to their uh other truly native
apps so there's a link to the itunes
store for the ios and to the google play
pla for for their android application as
well
but yeah you can see that display
standalone
default orientation portrait the theme
color
background color start url the name of
the app
and that's it all of that all you can
see on my screen right now
uh is what you need as a manifest to get
things started
and even this one is actually a little
bit more complex than
a base manifest related applications is
not needed
you could really just have a name and an
icon
and and that that would do so it could
be even more basic than this
so in the chrome dev tools i can explore
the manifest so these are all of the
icons
found in the manifest
as the different colors and everything
and i can even see the service worker
so there is a service worker a link up
here
which is going to show me when it was
installed
so last time it was received and is it
running or not
i could force to unregister that service
worker or forced to update it
um i can simulate offline from here so i
could click offline and then i would see
how this app behaves if i go offline for
instance
and if i want to see the source code
there's a link to the source as well so
if i click on
here i get to source and i can tell
right away
that the service worker for starbucks
was built with workbox
because it shows right here and that
you're pre-caching
a lot of things such as images
css javascript which makes perfect sense
if you want the app to um
to show up offline uh without any
connection
or to be able to to reload pretty
quickly you would need to cache
all of that up front so that's uh that's
how they've done it
and and they use the worldblocks to make
this happen
so another feature i mentioned earlier
was notifications
so these notifications um you can you
can use them in
regular javascript these days so you you
don't
need a pwa to do notifications per se
um but but it's an it could be a nice
addition to to
your app um if if of course these
notifications bring value to the user
um there is a website that you can use
so this one
up here is a notification generator
that shows you all of the options
available to play
with notifications in a browser
and you'll see that it's it's actually
quite a lot there's a lot of options
here
you can add icons you can add actions
to um to your notification so buttons
like yes no
or okay cancel those sort of things um
you can make the notification silence
you can decide what happens when the
notification gets closed as well
so i encourage you to take a look at
this website and play around with it
try to customize the notifications and
then you can click the display
button down here and it will show you
the notification
in so if you're using a web browser on a
pc or laptop
you would see the the native operating
system
a notification rendering for that if
you're using it
on your phone then you would see the uh
the native behavior for your phone in
here
and one more tool i want to to talk
about
which is very important when you build
a progressive web apps is lighthouse
so lighthouse is another
tool from google that you can use to
audit
your progressive web app and it can be
found in the dev tools
of um of google chrome so
if you go to a web app you navigate to
the audits section
and you'll see a button performance
audit and when you run that audit
it is just going to take the app and and
run a bunch of tests on it
um these stats are so there's several
sections one of them is pwa
it's also going to test your app for
search engine optimization
speed um all of these different things
that you can
think of to make your app better
so if i go to google chrome and
navigate to audits oh i have my app
open multiple times i have to close that
yeah not sure it's gonna work here but
that's okay
uh yeah it looks like i have this open
in two too many different places so it's
not gonna run the report
but that's where you can find it so in
your left tools you go to audits
this is the lighthouse tool and it's
gonna it can run
reports on all of these categories so
performance pwa
best practices accessibility and seo
and the nice part about lighthouse is
that it's gonna give you a score
on all of these categories and uh if
you're doing something wrong it's gonna
tell you exactly what to do to fix it
so for instance a common mistake
that people make is that their images
are too big
way too big and
and and and this would catch it and say
oh this image here is it's like five
megabytes you have to do something with
it because
it would never load on on a smartphone
or those sort of things
so um pretty pretty impressive tool when
you run it you learn a lot
and it's gonna give you great insights
about what to do to make your app better
um so yeah from from progressive web
perspective it's gonna check your
manifest it's gonna check
that your icons are all good
that your service worker gets installed
and all of these different things
it takes probably a couple of minutes to
run the audit
uh but it's definitely worth it saves a
lot of
time in the long run and gives you a ton
of info
so the title of my talk was how
progressive web apps the future
and the thing is they are they are still
work in progress uh in a sense that
not all browsers support progressive web
apps right now
it is getting close to it
apple has been a little bit slower in
adopting progressive web apps because
well you you can really see that as some
sort of competition
to to itunes so it's been a little bit
slower on
uh apple's slide side to go with
with pwas but it's it's happening uh
and and should be there if not already
this year because the thing is
progressive web apps are a w3c standard
so the app manifests the service workers
the notifications
everything i talked about it has to be
supported
by every single browser they have to
it's part of the spec
it's part of the w3c standard
which means that it's gonna happen and
it's gonna become
universal support all over the place at
some point
and the starbucks app that i showed you
uh
probably started at least two or three
years ago
um i've been doing this talk for a while
and uh
yeah i would say two or three years ago
so progressive web apps
have been around for for a few years
already
the support is becoming much better over
time and then and hopefully this year
will be able to just use them
in any browser and will have this
all of these features enable enabled no
matter
no matter which mobile device we're
using
you can already find a few directories
of pwas
so there are two examples here pwa
directory
dot appspot.com and pwa.rux
these ones date from years ago when pwas
got started so you'll see a lot of
tiny games or like kind of to-do list
examples
most of them work offline they do
notifications they do all of these
things
that i talked about so if you want to
play around and test a few progressive
web apps
that's a great place to go and then take
a look at
alright that was my last slide